so
today we'll be talking about model-based
reinforcement learning and how it can be
used for multi-task learning
so
for today first we're going to recap
goal-conditioned reinforcement learning
and relabeling then we'll talk about
model-based reinforcement learning
and how it can be used for multi-task
learning
and then we'll talk about model-based rl
when you have higher dimensional
observations such as images
and the goals for today will be
to allow you to understand how to use
and implement model-based reinforcement
learning methods
how to
use um how model-based reinforcement
learning can be used for multi-task
learning
and challenges and strategies for
model-based rl when you have
high-dimensional observation spaces
great so let's start with the recap
um last monday before the project
presentations or before the proposal
presentations we talked about
uh
first briefly overviewing reinforcement
learning
uh and
in particular carl introduced model-free
reinforcement learning methods including
policy gradients
and uh and q learning
reinforcement
carl talked about how reinforcement
learning algorithms in general follow
this structure where you first
generate samples by running the policy
fit some model to estimate the return
that those samples get
and then use that model to improve your
policy
we saw two different ways for doing this
the first was using policy gradients
um which
fits some kind of a model to estimate
the return by simply
looking at monte carlo rollouts of your
policy and computing the discounted
return from that rollout
and the second approach is to use q
learning where you fit a q function
using the bellman equation to estimate
your return
both of these are two ways that you can
use to estimate your turn one where you
just average over the directories and
one where you actually fit something
like like a neural network
and then once you have this model of the
return you can either use it to directly
update your policy using a policy
gradient
or
use
use basically
your q function take the maximum over
actions to get the best action for your
policy
okay um and then so these are kind of
two model free reinforcement learning
methods and then later in this lecture
once we get into the core of the lecture
we'll focus on model-based reinforcement
learning methods
uh we also talked about what is a
reinforcement learning task um we talked
about how basically a task corresponds
to
a markov decision process with a state
space an action space an initial state
distribution transition dynamics and a
reward where all of these might vary
across different tasks
and
you can alternatively view a multi-task
reinforcement learning problem as
something that tries to integrate a task
identifier into your representation of
the state
where uh where this s bar is the
original state
so this just puts the multitask uh the
set of mdps into a single mdp
where
um
you can then condition your policy and
condition your q function on the task
identifier in order to get a multi-task
policy or a multitask q function
uh what does di correspond to um this
can correspond to a range of things
can correspond to a one hot task
identifier
which is the simplest case it can
correspond to a language description of
the task
this would correspond to an instruction
following setting
and it can also correspond to a desired
goal state
so you could have a multi-task rl
problem where different tasks correspond
to trying to reach different states
different goal states
and this is a special case of multi-task
reinforcement learning that's called
goal conditioned rl
in the sense that you are going to be
conditioning your policy and your q
function on the goal that you want to
reach
and you're going to be training these
polls this policy and this q function
to reach goals
okay um
with this we can look at an example of a
multitasker rl problem so this is the
example that that carl gave last week
where you have a hockey player
maybe there's a hockey player has a
teammate as well as someone on the other
team that's defending the goal and you
have two tasks one task is to pass it to
the teammate and another task is to
shoot goals
and in this example if you think about
the case of a setting where maybe you
were trying to
shoot a goal but you accidentally
performed a great pass to your teammate
in this case it makes sense to actually
share that data
and not just use that data for
the task of cheating the goal but also
use that data for training your passing
policy
so to do this you can store your
experience as normal but also
relabel your experience and
relabel it with kind of the id
of this um
of the id of task one for example if
you're originally trying to
uh
trying to do test chest two so this
actually should be test one um say that
okay in retrospect i was let's say that
i was pretending to perform task one i
was pretending to pass i did a great job
at passing you can store that with uh
store that experience with the
corresponding task id and the reward and
allow yourself to learn
with that data for both this new task as
well as the original task that you were
attempting
this is what's called hindsight
relabeling
um it's also also referred to hindsight
experience replay or her
and the way this works as an algorithm
is you collect data
that has the original states the actions
the goal state that you are attempting
and the rewards using some policy
you then store that data in your replay
buffer
and then when you want to perform
hindsight relabeling
you
re-label your experience in dk using the
last state that you reached as the goal
so instead of storing it with the goal
state that you are attempting
you can
replace that goal state with the state
that you reached in practice and this
gives you an example of a success
for that state
and then you also set the reward to be
something like the negative distance
between the current state and that goal
that new goal state
once you store this relabeled data in
your replay buffer
you can then update your policy using
using all of the data that you
that you have including the relabeled
data
and then you can iteratively apply this
process
there may be other relabeling strategies
as well so in this case we relabeled
with the final state that we reached as
the goal but you could also use any
state from the directory um
this will allow you to alleviate
exploration challenges by trying to
target the way that you share data
across tasks
okay is there any questions on this
process
hello yeah go ahead so uh from this uh
slide it seems to the final state has a
big key
it's like your target state but how can
you make sure that's the case
yeah so basically before your when you
collected the data your goal state was
randomly sampled for example and stored
in your data and this is saying in
retrospect let's say that my goal was
actually the state that i reached and
store the data
with that kind of state that i reached
as the goal
okay okay
any other questions
so this is the algorithm that you'll be
implementing in homework three
uh i have one question
the last step that is reached uh is like
not a good state for the task let's say
in the case of example of the hockey
player uh the
uh bot
scores an own goal so like that's not a
good state to be in
so but we do not want to reward like
train on that particular kind of
strategy because that would be like
unreasonable so
so if that's a goal that you don't want
to reach
um note that in this case we're still
passing in the goal to our policy so
we're training our policy with um
like a
given s and s g and so essentially what
this is going to be doing is it's going
to be training it such that if you
wanted to score a goal on yourself for
example
with that particular goal state
then
that's the way that you should that's
kind of an example
of how you could do that
um this won't necessarily harm the other
policies it won't tell the other
policies for other goals
to stop stor to score a goal on yourself
um
it's going only going to be rewarding
the policy with that goal
to um
to that that's actually a good thing to
do with that goal state that's a good
thing to do so basically if st is
the
um
is scoring goal on yourself then you'll
set that to be
the goal state here
and you'll give it a high reward for
doing that but of course only for
this policy
okay thank you
do you have a question
sorry i was muted um um yeah i'm
assuming here that um we want to be
selective um in terms of what we add to
the replay buffer um so is this strictly
driven by the reward um like at the end
of the episode we look at the reward and
then we um
we think that oh yeah this is a this is
a good result and and that's what i will
add to the replay buffer
yeah so the intermission here is that if
you choose the last state or one of the
states in the trajectory that's an
example of something that you achieved
on accident and you're kind of you can
use that kind of accidental success
as like
data for as if you did want to
accomplish that
um
if if those kinds of goals are things
that you don't care about like scoring a
goal on yourself for example you could
choose to
only relabel within the set of goals
that you care about for example
um
there's also kind of a generalization of
this where you could instead of
in the setting where you're goal
conditioned if you're in a multitask
setting you could see if the experience
you collected was had a high reward for
any of the tasks and relabel for tasks
that it has high rewards for
um and
this is kind of a heuristic that allows
you to store data that is successful for
different tasks that you weren't trying
to accomplish
um you could also store data for in in
other ways uh this isn't the only way to
relabel your data um this is just one
heuristic that tends to work well
because
of the
um
because it stores basically successes of
these other tasks
does that answer your question
yeah and it's asking so basically this
allows us to gain a lot of data for
potential successes right
and that's exactly right
um
it is asking so are we adding more tasks
by adding different goal states uh and
that's also kind of
generally correct
basically each goal state corresponds to
a different task and each time you add
each time you kind of experience
reaching a new goal state that you
hadn't seen in your data before that may
actually correspond to adding a new task
is asking does relabeling significantly
slow down the training process
uh it will increase your replay buffer
size but
it
won't necessarily slow down the process
of learning
in comparison to goal condition learning
and actually typically it makes
typically it makes learning actually
faster and more efficient because it
actually helps alleviate exploration
challenges by storing data of successes
and then is asking shouldn't we
constrain that if st is one of the goal
states for one of the tasks that we
won't perform and then only perform this
augmentation
yeah so
if you have a set of tasks that you
really that are the ones that you care
most about
then you could choose to relabel only
for those sets of tasks so basically
have a rule
here that says like
if
st
is like in my set of goal states
um one of the reasons that we may not
want to do this i think this could be a
very reasonable way to approach things
um one reason that where it may make
sense to actually re-label with
any possible state is that it may
actually help the model
learn about general ways to reach states
and that kind of general learning
process about how to reach different
states may be useful
for the weights of the model to learn
how to accomplish different kinds of
goals
okay
great and then also with regard going
back to the question about it slowing
down training you'll also get an
opportunity to experiment with this in
your homework so you'll be able to to
understand exactly what the
ramifications are
okay um and then how does this actually
work in practice so
the 2017 paper that introduced uh this
concept um that was actually also
somewhat introduced in this 1993 paper
by leslie cabling
it experimented the 2017 paper
experimented with the simulated robotic
manipulation task where tasks
corresponded to
pushing sliding and pick and place
of objects on a table
and what they find is that when you use
relabeling which is in the blue and the
red curve here they have two different
versions of it
they find that you're able to get pretty
substantial benefits over
either count based exploration or just a
vanilla version of the algorithm
which is kind of evidence for how well
or how this can alleviate challenges
with exploration
okay
great so
that's a brief recap of what was covered
on monday last week with regard to
reinforcement learning and goal
condition reinforcement learning
uh now we'll get to the kind of core
part of this lecture on model-based
reinforcement learning and how it can be
used for multi-test learning
so
uh the main idea behind model-based
reinforcement learning is that you're
going to learn a model of the
environment dynamics
and the reason why you might do this is
that it often leads to better data
efficiency
because if you learn a model of the
environment you can then actually
leverage that model when figuring out
what to do rather than collecting data
from the real environment
and this allows the model to be easily
reused and as we'll talk about in a
couple slides the model can actually be
reused across different tasks in many
different contexts
the way that it looks like in the
context of this loop that we talked
about before is
when we're fitting a model we are
estimating the transition dynamics using
some neural network
in the slides i'll denote this as a
deterministic neural network that
predicts s prime from s and a but in
practice this network may actually
be stochastic in order to capture
stochasticity in the real world
and this just kind of comes down to a
supervised learning problem where you
want to minimize the error between your
predicted next state and the true next
state
then once you
learn this model you can then optimize
for behavior
uh or for a policy using that model and
we'll talk about exactly how that
happens in a couple slides
but kind of at a high level we're gonna
be fitting a model of the environment
and the dynamics and then using that
model to improve the policy
okay so what does this have to do with
multi-task reinforcement learning
before we talked about multi-task
reinforcement learning as having
potentially different dynamics different
word functions different states and
different action spaces
and
one observation here is that in many
situations the only thing that varies
across tasks is just the reward function
and in particular today we're going to
focus exactly on the special case where
the state space the action space the
initial state distribution and the
dynamics are the same across all of the
tasks
and only the reward function varies with
the task
and a few examples of where this may
come up um
one example is robotics where the laws
of physics are staying constant across
tasks
but you want the robot to complete
different objectives so maybe you want
to do laundry maybe you want to be able
to cook for you and so forth um in this
case maybe the dynamics are will often
be the same and the only thing that's
different is the reward function that
you're giving it for doing these
different tasks
another example is in a task driven
dialogue system
where maybe the user that
that the dialog system is interacting
with is is constant and the language is
also the same
but the user has different objectives
that it wants this dialogue agent to be
able to complete
in different scenarios maybe in some
snare in one scenario it wants the user
wants the the dialogue agent to order
food in another scenario it wants it to
provide emotional support and so forth
and then one third example where this
special case also holds
is in autonomous driving
for example maybe the rules of the road
stay constant over time
you're always in the same country or in
the same kind of region of the world
but
what might be varying is different user
preferences
so different tasks would correspond to
driving for different people and one
person may want the the car to go very
fast another person may want the car to
drive very smoothly
okay so this is a special case that
we'll focus on today uh and in future
lectures we will also be considering
scenarios where things like the dynamics
may be changing over time
now one thing that's nice about the
special case is that now
estimating the model
is just a single task problem
you just need to learn a single model of
the world
uh because that's constant and only the
reward is changing
so that means that we can kind of
readily apply
several standard model based single task
learning
methods
for the multi-task for these multi-task
reinforcement learning cases
okay so
how do these how do model-based rl
algorithms work and how do they optimize
these objectives
so the first approach that we'll
consider is optimizing over the actions
using the model
there's a few different ways that we
could do this this is also referred to
as planning
in the sense that you're planning a
course of action
using the
model and the task that you want to
complete
the
first way that you could imagine doing
this
to optimize over these actions is just
with back propagation so you could take
your reward function and back propagate
gradients through your model
into
your sequence of actions
and
optimize over a sequence of actions with
gradient descent that lead to high
a high sum of rewards
so this could be with a gradient-based
optimization
and the way this algorithm works is you
first run some policy to collect data
you then learn a model to minimize
your model error
and then you back propagate through that
model to choose a sequence of actions
a1
through a t for example
and then you execute those actions
uh and you can also
you can back propagate to just choose
those actions directly and execute those
actions directly
or you could pass those gradients into a
policy and optimize over the parameters
of this policy
any questions on how this works at a
high level
um just a question about steps two and
three so we're using the
same trajectories um to minimize like
the
model of the environment as well as um
the policy
yeah this is a good question so
we will um
i guess so in this case we're using this
is gonna
this is gonna be using your data
in this step um
it depends on how you optimize but you
don't actually necessarily need data for
this step
so
for example say the case that you're not
you're just optimizing over a sequence
of actions
uh a1 through t
what you can do is you can just randomly
initialize these actions
and then pass them through the model
and kind of iteratively
maybe this is kind of the first
iteration
iteratively update and optimize the
sequence of actions such that it
maximizes
the reward or the sum of rewards
and to do this optimization you don't
actually need to
optimize it over data because you're
optimizing over the action sequences and
you can actually generate kind of fake
data from
the model itself
okay
asking does it require a continuous
action space for back propagation to
work uh the short answer is
yes
although there are also gradient
estimators that
can approximate gradients through
discrete things this includes things
like the straight through estimator
gumball softmax
et cetera
do you have a question
yes so i just want to clarify that in
step 3 we do not
run simulations over
uh learning simulations and interact
with the environment we only use this
learned app to transactions
correct yeah so step three isn't isn't
involving the environment in any way
you're just kind of involving your
learned model which can be viewed as a
learned model of the environment which
you're using to optimize it for your
actions
okay
then another approach that we could use
instead of a gradient based optimization
over actions
is uh
to use sampling which will essentially
just correspond to a gradient free
optimization
and
can actually work surprisingly well in
some cases
and the intuition for why gradient free
optimization might make sense
is that
the sequence of actions may be fairly
low dimensional
certainly lower dimensional than the
size of a neural network parameter
vector
and the way this works is the kind of
the first two steps are the same you
collect some data you
train a model
and the third step is a little bit
different so instead of doing a gradient
based optimization you instead
iteratively sample
a large number of action sequences
run those action sequences through the
model
and either pick the model either pick
the action sequence that led to the
highest reward
or
pick the kind of the top
k percent of
action sequences
and then kind of iteratively refine
that set of
um that set of action sequences where
for example you can
uh
pick the top k percent fit a new
distribution to that top k percent
resample from that distribution and and
allow yourself to iteratively
get a better and better
uh sequence of actions
so there's a variety of grading free
optimization approaches that you can use
one is what's called uh
random shooting
which is simply where
you just randomly sample a bunch of
action sequences and kind of shoot them
out which is why it's called shooting
and then pick the one that works the
best
another is called the cross entropy
method
or yeah um
which may
sound a little bit confusing it doesn't
really have
much to do with the cross entropy loss
which is the iterative
the iterative approach that i mentioned
before
and there's also things like um
like evolutionary methods
which are other forms of gradient free
optimizations
one thing that is is nice about this is
it's pretty easy to apply these methods
to discrete action spaces um although it
also actually works
pretty well for short horizon continuous
action spaces
okay
so now
this is kind of v1
how can this approach
fail
does anyone have thoughts on what might
go wrong with this approach
feel free to either raise your hand or
answer in chat
any guesses
yeah so there's one one comment from
which is that there's no exploration so
the model might always choose
uh from a small set of actions that may
not be very good
um
mentions that it ignores future rewards
after the horizon so yeah each of these
approaches were only optimizing for
a fixed horizon of um kind of a fixed
a fixed horizon from like one to t for
example and if you have a very long
horizon problem this may not work well
mentioning that uh if the model is
inaccurate you're going to have
compounding errors because you need to
predict multiple time steps into the
future and if it starts if it if you get
a small error from the model and it
starts to kind of fall off the manifold
of what it's seen before then it's going
to make bigger and bigger errors
and uh and be actually quite inaccurate
as you have longer horizons
is hypothesizing that maybe there are
problems with inaccuracies in the data
cool so all of these are all these are
good answers
um
the main thing that that i actually have
on the sides is uh
is the point which is that
the
action optimization if you have an
inaccurate model especially when you
have compounding errors over time
this optimization over actions will
exploit any imprecisions in the model
so if the model is
erroneously optimistic about one set of
action sequences leading to high reward
then it will it's going to try to
actually
find the actions in which the model is
inaccurate because it leads because the
model is telling you that that leads to
high reward
now
one really easy way to fix this to some
degree is to refit the model using new
data so this will specifically happen
when
the model specifically will be imprecise
it's off of the manifold of data that's
seen before during training
and what we can do is we can then
collect new data
from
the action sequences that we optimized
which will precisely be in the
situations where our model may be
inaccurate and use that data to retrain
our model to be accurate in those
regions
so we can basically just add a fourth
step to
this algorithm where we actually execute
the planned actions and then append the
visiting data to our data set
and then retrain our model using all of
the data that we've seen so far
okay so that's kind of
this is kind of the the full
version one of the algorithm
uh
even in this case uh
it can be
refitting the model using new data will
definitely help with these sorts of
imprecisions um but in the general case
learning a good global model is pretty
difficult
there are a few different ways for
tackling this problem um
one
additional way that we can use to tackle
this problem
is whenever we find ourselves in a new
state
you can instead of just kind of keep on
executing the plan that you had come on
that you would
derive before actually replan using your
model at that new state and this can
allow you to potentially kind of correct
for errors that you made at that
previous time step
and this is this is what's called model
predictive control or mpc
uh which is a bit of a fancy name but
the gist of what it means is to plan and
then replan using your model
so
the way this looks like is you first run
your run some initial policy to collect
data learn a model using that data
use your model to optimize different
action sequence
all of these first three steps are the
same as before
now what we're going to do is we're
going to
execute the first planned action
so in this case maybe we're at time step
t we optimized for
an action sequence from
a t to a t plus h
and here we're going to execute only
a t
observe the next state
append this to our data and then we're
actually going to kind of re-plan at the
next time step now we'll be at kind of
replanting
a t plus 1
through a t plus 1 plus h
i'll write it down here
and then again executing the first
planned action
and of course you can also still have
this outer loop that retrains your model
as you see more and more data
and essentially what this allows you to
do is you start making a wrong turn and
see yourself in a state that you didn't
expect to be in
then you can correct yourself
at the next time step
and this can actually help
a lot with model errors including
compounding errors
the downside is that it's actually
pretty compute intensive because you
need to run the planning process
much more frequently than just at the
very beginning of
the trajectory
so this is one approach that can help
with model errors um there's a number of
other approaches as well that we won't
have time to get into this includes
things like
uncertainty estimation where you try to
measure the uncertainty of your model
and be conservative with regard to your
model's uncertainty there's also
approaches that try to use only a local
model and constrain the action
optimization to be close to where the
model is accurate
okay
so that's the gist of how model based
reinforcement learning algorithms work
what does this have to do with multitask
reinforcement learning
um
how you actually apply this to a
multitasker rl problem depends on the
form of your reward function
so if you know exactly if you know what
the reward function is
if you know how to evaluate it
then
you can just learn a single model of the
dynamics and then when you run the
planning procedure to optimize over your
actions
just whenever you
do that planning process you consider
the reward function that you care about
at test time and plan with respect to
that reward function
uh so
for example uh
this is actually a recent paper from a
year ago
where reward functions correspond to
different pencil trajectories
and it's basically able to re-plan with
a single model to write different digits
so here's like a a digit i think a five
i think there's a four here a seven here
and so forth
so it can use its model and plan with
regard to these different
different tasks of writing different
digits
another example is the different tasks
may correspond to trying to manipulate
balls in the palm of the hand
i think they're called bounding balls in
this case
and for example this first task may be
to rotate them
counterclockwise
a second task might be to simply just
put this ball in a certain position as
indicated by the
the red dot it's a little bit hard to
see
and then the third task might be to
rotate the bounding balls clockwise
which the the model is also able to
figure out how to do
uh and one of the pretty cool things
about this
um oh actually before i go into that one
caveat here is that the reward function
will actually change how you collect the
data so if you have that outer loop
that's actually collecting that's
telling you to collect data um
basically collecting data based on the
actions that you select then you'll want
to be collecting data for these
different reward functions rather than
just collecting data for a single reward
function and then trying to generalize
to a new reward function
um
one last note is that uh these
algorithms are actually quite sample and
sample efficient and they're actually
efficient enough to be able to train for
this task on a real robot
i think that it took
on the outer on the order of a couple
hours to learn how to
manipulate these bounding balls in the
real world
okay
so that's the case where we know the
reward function uh in this case the
reward function was just for example the
position between the goal position the
negative distance between the goal
position of each of the balls and the
true position
of the balls
or
the
distance between the trajectory that was
drawn
and the goal trajectory
but in other cases you don't necessarily
know exactly what the form of the reward
function is for each of the tests
and so you might need to actually learn
a model of the reward function
which you can just learn with multi-task
reinforcement learning or sorry with
multi-task
it's just standard multi-test learning
or
you could also use metal learning to
metal learn a reward function with a
little bit of data with a few examples
of what that task is
and then once you get this kind of
parametric form of the reward you can
use that to plan
so as an example of what this looks like
uh say you want the robot to
put this pencil case
uh
above or behind the notebook
we can give it a training data set that
has a few positive examples
and then use this
use this data set to acquire
a
success classifier or basically a binary
reward function that's one
when it's behind and zero otherwise
and then once you kind of adapt your
model using the training data set
you can then plan using your model to
maximize reward
and this is what kind of the executed
trajectory looks like after you plan
with regard to the task of
of pushing the pencil case behind the
notebook
okay
so any questions on model based rl for
these multitask learning problems
sorry can you just go over what do you
mean by like the form of the rewards
yeah so what i mean by that is
do you basically have an equation
that tells you
like what r is as a function of s and a
and so in the case of
like writing um in the case of writing a
digit or like
trying to manipulate a ball to a certain
location the reward function may kind of
be something that equals
the negative like distance between the
state
and like the goal state
for that ball
and if you have this equation
then you can just learn a model and plan
with respect to this equation
if you don't have this equation for
example if your states are images and
your reward is like
one if you were successful and zero if
you weren't successful
then you need to actually
actually be able to optimize over
actions you need some equation that
gives you the reward from the states
and if you don't have that equation then
you can basically train a neural network
to tell you what the reward is given
uh given a state in action and
your your task identifier or your
training data okay so it's just
basically whether you have like an
explicit like formulation of the reward
or versus having to like learn it okay
thank you exactly yeah
asking do we need to do reward shaping
this is a good question so
model based reinforcement learning
methods typically
typically work
better for shorter horizon problems
because if you have a very long horizon
problem and as far as reward then you
need to roll out your model for a long
period of time and it may be difficult
your model probably won't be accurate
for that long of a horizon
if you instead have a long horizon
problem with a very shaped reward then
model based planning will be feasible or
if you have a short horizon problem with
a sparse reward it will also be feasible
so this example on the side right here
is an example of a sparse reward where
you just get one for success and zero
otherwise
but it's fairly short horizon because
the robot only needs to kind of
kind of move his arm down and move the
pencil case to the left
yeah and then he's asking can you
explain again what do you mean by the
reward will change how you collect data
so the reason why this is is
basically here so
when you are
optimizing over your action sequences
to choose actions
you're going to be kind of
optimizing for your action sequences
with regard to your reward function
and then once you
actually try to solve that task you're
going to be adding this data to your
data set that's being used to train your
model and so if one task is to like move
an object over here another task is to
move an object over here and you only
train with regard to that first task
you're not going to see data of trying
to move the object to the second
position and this will make it harder to
actually perform that second that second
task because the model won't be very
accurate for those states
um is asking the assumption here is that
the middle learning model accuracy is a
hundred percent
uh it doesn't need to be exactly a
hundred percent i think you're referring
to
this point right here but it does need
to be fairly accurate
if it makes
uh if it starts to make a lot of
mistakes then your model is going to
kind of exploit those mistakes just like
how it exploits errors in the dynamics
model
uh
asking is learning the reward function a
supervised learning problem so
yes so in um in this case this is
basically a multitask supervised
learning problem because you assume you
have some labels of the reward function
and you want to be able to predict those
labels uh but it's a multitask problem
in the sense that you probably are
predicting the rewards for multiple
different tasks
uh and here it's basically equivalent to
a meddlering problem in the supervised
case
and then asking is the outcome of this
equivalent to training a joint mdp
across these tasks
i'm not sure exactly what you mean by
training and joint mdp because the mdp
is the task itself
but it um this is one approach for kind
of
solving
uh a policy or solving for behaviors
across all of these tests
okay so i think those are all the
questions
now that we've kind of gone over the
basics of model-based reinforcement
learning for multitask learning
let's talk about the scenario where we
have image observations because things
get a bit harder in that case
so
for example we can take this graphical
model here um that's similar to the one
that that carl showed on monday last
week
where
you have you can kind of directly
observe the observations o and you can't
observe the underlying states
so as a concrete example say you want
your robot to be able to use the spatula
to lift up this object and put it into
the bowl
and the only thing that you have access
to is
the kind of this camera image and the
robot can't directly access for example
the position of the bowl or the position
of the object
um also when you have images you don't
necessarily have a direct reward signal
you can train a classifier but you don't
know the the formula according to for
the reward function
so yeah as i mentioned you can learn
image classifier to get the reward
function another thing that you could do
is provide an image of the goal so you
could provide an image that looks like
this
uh and try to reach that image
so
these are kind of the approaches or
options that we can use for specifying
the reward
there are a few different approaches for
model based rl when you have these kinds
of image observations
one is to learn a model in some latent
representation space
another is to learn a model directly of
the observations and the third is to
learn a model of some alternative
quantities
and we'll go over each of these
approaches
for the remaining of for the remaining
time of the lecture
so let's first talk about learning
models in latent space
the kind of key idea here is that we're
going to learn in embedding
that
kind of embeds our observations into
some usually lower dimensional space
and then just treat that lower
dimensional space as our state space
so for example if this is kind of our
original graphical model we can
basically just try to learn
an encoder that maps us back from from
the observations back to our states
and then once you learn this embedding
you can just do the same sort of model
based url in that latent space
so this sounds pretty simple um there
are a couple papers that do this uh or
there's a couple papers that did this
back um like four or five years ago
they're actually still fairly
representative of the kinds of latent
space models that people use today so
we'll talk about these
i can also talk about extensions on
these and more recent approaches if
people are interested
and the algorithm looks something like
this so you run some policy to collect
data
you then learn
a latent betting of your observation
space
that maps from o to s
and a model
in that latent
space then you can use this model to
optimize over
a set of action sequences
just like before
and then execute your planned actions
and append the visited observation
action next observation tuples to your
data set
cool so there are a couple questions
that arise
from this algorithm this is basically
the same as before but it's just
additional step of embedding the
observation space
the first question that comes up is what
is the reward function for optimizing
for your actions
uh the reward function that we'll use
and that's that's most commonly used is
just to
given the the goal state that you're
given just measure the negative distance
between your embedded state your
embedded observation and your embedded
goal observation
uh so this is a pretty simple approach
again like i mentioned you could also
use something like classifier or if you
do have observations of the rewards you
could learn a model of your rewards
on top of your
learned observation space
so you can learn something like this
but in practice often approaches you
something like this because you often
don't getting reward functions
is actually pretty tricky in practice
yeah so
asking in the spatula example would we
be learning a model that maps images to
the spatula orientation and location
um
that would roughly be the goal uh
although we would also want it to model
things like the object and the bowl and
not just the spatula
in practice uh i guess we'll talk about
how we go about learning this embedding
space on the next slide
one critical assumption with this reward
function is that this distance
in this latent space is actually an
accurate metric
uh this assumption
is actually pretty tricky in practice
because even if this
this representation even if this
representation space is useful for
modeling the dynamics uh distances in
that space may not actually be
meaningful
um this may be something like
yeah this is something like the l2
metric uh you could also use other
metrics in this space as well
okay so now how do we go about actually
optimizing for the latent embedding
space
uh
what this first paper did is they
learned an embedding and a model jointly
so they basically took something that
looks like a variational auto encoder
except over two time steps
and jointly learned how to reconstruct
images they basically directly learned
uh
kind of g of o mapping to s
also
they learned in a decoder that maps from
s
back to the original space
and then they finally also learned
something that maps from s and a
to s prime
this is the gist of the model um
it's a little bit more complicated than
that because uh it's actually kind of
building upon variational inference but
if you're interested in the details you
can take a look at the paper
and
in this case they were
trying to
reach different goal states so
as an example they would give it a goal
state that looks like this where the arm
is kind of reached out to the top right
and then here's an example of a
trajectory that's trying to reach that
that state
and you can see both the trajectory of
the arm on the left and also
the kind of the prediction from the
previous time step so these are kind of
reconstructed images of the state
now if we give it a different uh a
different task which is to kind of curl
the arm
upward
you can also figure out how to reach
this
and then finally there's a third example
where the arm is kind of reaching
downward uh and it's given this goal
state and is trying to plan to reach the
state
um and each of these were actually or
all this was actually learned with only
around 300 trials which would correspond
to about 25 minutes of robot time per
task
which is quite efficient
uh and then
another way to optimize for a latent
embedding space is to try to
incorporate a little bit more structure
into the process
and so in this work i was trying to
optimize first latent embedding space
where the latent space corresponded to
points in 2d
and as a result of kind of imposing the
structure on the latent space
it led to kind of features that tracked
the objects
through
track the objects through time
and specifically what it looks like is
it's an auto encoder where the
um where the goal is to
reconstruct images we wanted to impose
this 2d structure onto the latent
representation
so to do that the last convolutional
layer
uh
on top of the last convolutional layer
there's this spatial softmax which
essentially exponentiates
each of the
each of the activations and then
normalizes
over the activations within the spatial
dimensions
and so each of these different feature
maps here correspond to different
distributions
over the spatial extent of the feature
mode
and then once you have this distribution
over locations essentially you can then
compute the expected location of each of
those distributions to give you
essentially expected xy coordinates for
each of these feature maps
so then as a result this is kind of a 32
dimensional vector where you get two
dimensions for each of these feature
maps
one for the x and one for the y
coordinate
uh and then you get something that looks
like this so this is visualizing only
two of the feature points but one of the
feature points tracks the the finger of
the robot and another one of them tracks
the object
i also mentioned that the the embedding
is smooth so there's actually an
additional loss on top of this
reconstruction loss that encourages the
feature points to
uh to kind of
that penalizes the
um the acceleration of the feature
points so you can encourage it to
maybe these future points are kind of
indicated by x y
uh you could encourage
the
maybe you have something like
this this is the velocity
of the
of the point essentially the difference
between the points positioned at t plus
one and the point at t
and if you want to penalize the
acceleration you can do something like
this where you compare the velocity at
this time step to the velocity at the
previous time step
this gives you something like the
acceleration and you can
penalize this by basically just putting
an l2 loss
on this to give you points that are
encouraged to be smooth over time
okay so this was the approach for
learning the future space
uh and then this is what the learning
process looks like so the policy in this
case the goal is to put the
the block somewhere over here
and the policy is initialized something
that knows how to move his arm to the
right position but not necessarily the
block
and
over time it uh is able to figure out
how to put the block in the correct
position
i may have drawn the blue square in
slightly the wrong position but it yeah
it's able to figure out how to put it in
the goal position
which was indicated by a um
by a goal image
here's the final policy that it learns
and then we can also do it for other
tasks so in this case this is the
spatula task that we were
uh that i gave with the initial
motivation and you can use this task to
learn how to lift the object into the
goal into the bowl given the goal image
and also in this case given the
uh the target configuration of the arm
lastly you can also actually visualize
the feature points so each of these
circles is the visualized feature point
for the image and the x's is the feature
points the kind of the encoded feature
points of the goal image
and you get trajectories that look like
this
where
the final policy is trying to match
try to minimize the distance between the
goal feature points and the uh
and the encoded future points
uh and
these skills were learned actually
individually in this case uh and
they were learning in about 11 minutes
of robot time per task
uh with the caveat that each of the
representations were actually learned
per task and per environment
okay so any questions on
any questions on
kind of learning and latent space
feel free to raise your hand
and looking at the questions in the chat
i think i answered most of them for the
most recent one
uh this does require that you have a
goal image from the same orientation as
your observations
otherwise it it may not work very well
okay so now one thought exercise uh feel
free to answer in chat or by raising
your hand
is both of these two approaches we're
learning the embedding space by like
with an auto encoder by reconstructing
the image and why not just learn the
embedding like why not just learn
g of o
to s by simply trying to minimize the
model error
of
the model in that latent space so say
you did we're just trying to
minimize this
with regard to the parameters of g
and
where you basically just like set s to
be the output of g
so what would happen in this case if you
just tried to minimize
kind of if you tried to optimize this
embedding with regard to the model error
in your latent space
so
said a long time before convergence bad
embedding would result in a bad model
and the model will be largely dependent
on the embedding
suggested that maybe there's a trivial
solution when the embedding is just
constant and it's also also suggested
that
uh so that's right so there's actually a
trivial solution to this which is that
if
if you optimize it only with respect to
the model error then your encoding can
just output because always output zero
deterministically for example
and then your model just has to always
predict zero
uh and this wouldn't lead to a very uh a
very useful embedding space right
so this is why it's important to have
some sort of objective
to prevent this
degenerate solution
so you need to do something it doesn't
need to be reconstruction but you need
to do something that prevents
um
that prevents the
the embedding from collapsing
okay so to summarize uh if you learn in
latent space
you found that you can learn complex
skills visual skills from images very
efficiently
it also things like structure
representations also enable this effect
effective learning the downside is that
reconstruction objectives may not
recover the right representation
so they're of course better than not
having the reconstruction objective
but for example um
in the work that i showed with the
spatula one of the tasks that i also
wanted the robot to be able to do
was to
like place a ping-pong ball in the
correct position so the ping pong ball
this is kind of a low dimensional image
of the robot with the ping pong ball
here
and if you trade an auto encoder on this
data
what you got for the reconstruction was
something that looks like this
so it essentially learned to erase the
ping pong ball because it was uh a very
small object that didn't actually
lead to a high reconstruction error
if it didn't reconstruct it
and of course the ping pong ball is like
in this case exactly what you wanted to
know
for the task
and this is an example of where a
reconstruction objective may not recover
the right representation
um
it may not actually focus on things that
are relevant for the task
and so this kind of suggests that we
need potentially better unsupervised
representation learning methods there
has been a lot of development on this in
kind of the last few years
uh
there's still kind of more work to be
seen
on whether these new methods are
effective for learning representations
for these kinds of tasks
do you have a question
yeah um would you be able to give some
examples of latent space
um
i just like i guess
something that lightens space it's not
just a picture
yeah so
you could also instead of having um
instead of having an image you could
also have other sensors so maybe
there's like in in robotics you could
have audio you could have tactile
sensors for example
and you may want to learn kind of a
latent representation of those sensor
readings
um beyond robotics in autonomous driving
you may have things like lidar readings
for example
um
if you're in a setting like language
language models work pretty well so you
could probably just model directly in
the space of language um
yeah those are those are a few examples
thanks
great and then just asking what happens
if you don't learn a latent space and
just feed the observations
into the dynamics model directly
uh and this is actually exactly what
we'll talk about next so we could
actually skip the aside we'll maybe get
back to it later
but what happens if we just model
directly in observation space
and this is actually something that we
can
absolutely do so we can just kind of
take the mpc algorithm that we did
before replace all of the s's with os
that's exactly what i did here
and train the model to operate directly
on your raw observations
so
what this might look like in the context
of robotics is you collect some data
so you can collect data that looks
something like this
uh this in this case this is actually
just a random policy
for the most part
then
you can train your model to minimize
prediction error
this actually corresponds to training a
video prediction model
and you can get predictions that look
something like this that's predicting
what the future will look like based on
the actions the robot takes
or basically what its future sensor
readings will show based on the actions
it takes
um you can also apply this to the the
towel data that i showed before to get
predictions that look like this
one of the things that's nice about
operating directly on observations is
that it means that you don't have to
prescribe a certain representation of
your state
and for example with deformable objects
it's actually quite hard to think about
how you would represent a towel for
example
and if you essentially just operate
directly
on your raw sensor observations then you
can train models like this
uh and then once you have this model you
can then use that model to optimize for
your action sequence with respect to
some reward function again your reward
function could be a classifier or be
some other metric that operates on your
predicted images
there's a couple details here so how do
you predict video
this corresponds to a video picture
model like i said before
there's a number of different models out
there some of the important elements of
this is to have a deep recurrent model
that predicts multiple frames into the
future
and it's also important for it to be
conditioned on the actions that you take
so that it predicts the future based on
the planned actions that you want to
take
uh and often these models are also
stochastic uh this is because there's
often a lot of uncertainty about what
the future will look like
and you want your model to be able to
capture that uncertainty rather than
simply blurring out
rather than simply kind of blurring the
things that it's not certain about
if you want an example of what kind of
the latest and greatest models look like
uh this is a paper from late last year
from reuben viagas
the left is showing the predictions from
the model and the right is showing the
grout truth on each of these pairs
and you see that it can actually predict
pretty well um what these like how the
robot will move and
how the objects will move in response to
the robot grasping the the shorts or
grasping the towel and moving it to a
desired location
okay so that's how you prick video how
do you plan
basically plan in the same exact way as
before for example you could use a
gradient free optimization or you could
you sample a large number of action
sequences including these two action
sequences
predict the future for each action
sequence
like as the predictions shown here
and then
pick the future that
is the most successful according to your
reward function
and execute the corresponding action
uh and then you can also repeat uh
if you want to re-plan you can also kind
of repeat these steps at each time step
or every couple of time steps
okay
um so it's essentially kind of mpc but
in the visual space or in the kind of
raw raw center space of these robots
um so how it works is you might specify
a goal uh there's i like i mentioned
before there's a number of different
ways to specify the goal uh
in in some of our recent work one way
that we specified the goal is specifying
where we want pixels to move in the
image
for example specifying that we want this
this red pixel to move up to where this
green pixel is and that we don't want
this pixel here to move
then we can run kind of visual mpc with
regard to this
with regard to this goal so we get a
prediction like this
that we think will accomplish the goal
and then we can execute those actions on
the robot
this is with a model that isn't quite as
precise as the the latest models that i
mentioned before but it can still
approximately accomplish the
task uh and of course one of the nice
things about these methods is that with
just a single video prediction model you
can accomplish not just one task but
many different tasks
uh assuming that kind of the dynamics of
individual space and of the world are
constant across these different tasks
so things like picking up an object
moving a sleeve towards
the edge of the shirt
picking up an apple and putting it on a
plate
you basically just need to kind of pass
in the task you want it to do and some
specification on images that allows it
to optimize with regard to that task
and then it can plan to accomplish the
task
using its video prediction model
so here are a few more examples
okay so the benefits of modeling
directly in image space is that this
order refresh can scale to real images
uh it also involves
fairly limited human involvement so
once you start just collecting data uh
training the model is actually fully
self-supervised
uh this is also true for the latent
space methods as well
um and actually unlike the lane space
methods for the most part we were able
to accomplish a wider variety of tasks
with a single model
uh some of the downsides is that
these images still do have limited
background variability and if you have a
lot of variability in the background and
the objects then these models can have
trouble capturing all of that diversity
um and the skills here are still
relatively simple that's kind of a
shortcoming
can be a shortcoming of a number of
different things including the capacity
of the model to model complex
interactions
uh and the ability to specify those
tasks
and the power of the planner to be able
to optimize for the right action
sequence to accomplish those tasks
and these methods are also quite compute
intensive because you have to actually
plan using a video prediction model
which is quite large
okay any questions on modeling directly
in your observation space
okay
so the last set of approaches that you
can consider is
predicting something other than
uh
other than some latent representation or
in the image predicting kind of
alternative quantities
and what this looks like is
in different scenarios you could ask
if i take a certain sequence of actions
will i successfully grasp an object or
will i collide with an object or
if i take a sequence of actions what
will my health or my damage be for
example
and
what this is doing is you basically
consider
different possible things that the
agent could do
and then you predict
the answer to this question you predict
and as a result of my actions
what is the outcome in terms of these
specific metrics
uh this succeed has a pretty close
connection to q learning uh so if you
actually set the reward to be the
probability of the event happening then
this actually corresponds uh
very closely to key learning
uh and this can be used uh for things
like grasping and avoiding collisions
and so forth and allows you to only
predict the qual the quantities that are
relevant to the task
the downside of course is that you need
to manually pick these quantities and
you must be able to directly observe
them
um in grasping you can kind of observe
when you've grasped something by like
looking at your fingers and seeing if
your fingers are closed or not
if your fingers aren't all the way
closed that suggests that you're
probably grasping something
uh and so forth but in a variety of
situations like for example the spatula
task you can't directly observe whether
or not the object is like you can't
directly observe like a binary indicator
for whether or not the um
for whether or not the object is in the
bowl
um once you learn a model like this it's
actually quite simple to actually
perform the task so for grasping for
example if you have something that tells
you given a sequence of actions whether
or not you'll successfully grasp then
you can then optimize over a set of
actions that lead to successful grasping
okay so
those are kind of the three core
approaches for model based reinforcement
learning
when you have high dimensional
observations
uh
just kind of
wrap up um
i'll talk a bit about some of the
takeaways between model based methods
and model free methods so uh today we
talked a lot about models
monday last week we talked a lot about
model free methods what are kind of the
trade-offs when considering these kinds
of methods
so the best
base methods is that it's easy to
collect data in a very scalable way
because you can train a model with data
that doesn't even have rewards labeled
it's also easy to transfer models across
reward functions
and they typically require a smaller
quantity of data that's supervised with
the reward
in practice
the downside is that models don't
optimize directly for task performance
and so they may there's a bit of a
mismatch between the objective and
sometimes the models may miss quantities
that are important for the task
and sometimes the model is harder to
learn than the policy so for example
training a video prediction model may be
more difficult than just predicting what
the correct action is
and then lastly you often need some some
assumptions in order to learn more
complex skills uh because you need to be
able to figure out you need to be able
to learn a model
that can uh
that is kind of suitable for those more
challenging interactions
for example if you have a lot of kind of
harsh contact dynamics then learning a
model that can accurately predict the
contact dynamics can be challenging
for model free methods
the upside is that they make very little
assumptions beyond having access to a
reward function
although having access to a reward
function can be a substantial assumption
in some applications
they're very effective for learning very
complex policies
or very learning very complex tasks
because they just have to learn a policy
they don't have to learn how the world
works
the downside is that they tend to
require a lot of data they're slower to
learn
and
um
it can involve a harder optimization
problem in the multi-task setting
because you aren't just training for a
single model of how things works you're
trying to optimize for
many different queue functions or or
basically the q function for many
different tasks or the policy for many
different tasks
uh and ultimately it's likely that we
probably want elements both in model
based learning and of model free
learning
they kind of both have benefits in
different scenarios
okay so
that's it for today uh
we kind of went over
the basics of model-based reinforcement
learning including how to implement
these kinds of algorithms how model
based rl can be used for multitask
problems and challenges and strategies
for handling high dimensional state
spaces with model based rl
uh
next time
we'll talk about meta reinforcement
learning so so far we've talked about
different ways to solve multitask
problems
and for the next three lectures we'll
focus on
solving meta-reinforcement learning
problems where you care about being able
to quickly learn a new task rather than
just learning a set of training tasks
hi i was wondering if you go back to the
part where you talked about learning a
um
mapping from the image to like a
physically meaningful
uh
representation yeah
i think that yeah you're one you're one
on the right i think um
but i i guess i was a bit confused about
um the whole like spatial soft mag stuff
going on and how you ended up with this
i thought it was really cool that you
ended up with like
the latent representation that like
actually corresponded to points but i
wanted to understand a bit better how
that worked
yeah so the way that it works is we kind
of assume that well i guess
first we basically have this operation
inside the neural network but i'll first
kind of emphasize that this autoencoder
is trained
end-to-end with regard to the
reconstruction objective
um so it's basically optimizing for a
set of 2d points such that it can
reconstruct the image effectively
now the special part about this auto
encoder is this operation where we're
essentially converting these feature
maps to these 2d points
and the way that we're constraining this
is
we basically take a soft max over the
extent of each of the feature maps
this gives us a distribution over each
of the feature maps
and then we can take the expectation
which is written by this equation right
here we'll take the expectation over
kind of the x extent which is shown here
which is basically computing the average
um
sorry so sij is computing is basically
the probability distribution
um
s is the probability value for
pixel i j
and this is computing the average
over
i and the average over j
and the result of this is basically how
the expected value of that kind of
distribution over coordinates which will
give you
a kind of a 2d coordinate in this space
and
both of these operations the softmax and
this expectation
are differentiable observation
operations which allow us to be able to
back propagate the reconstructed
reconstruction objective into the
earlier layers of the network
okay
so like each of the 16 distributions is
could be like its own object it's like a
probability distribution over where that
object is
yeah so it can basically correspond to
probability distributions over the
location of different objects
we give it 16 so that it can kind of
choose how it wants to use that itself
and based on how it's initialized it may
be easier for some distributions to
represent some objects than others
uh you may not have 16 objects in
practice of course so here we only have
like two primary objects of interest
um
yeah and
this is kind of what comes out of of
this kind of architecture
okay and you get the full auto encoder
like you train this on its own before
using it in any decision making it's
just like just auto encoder training
yeah exactly
okay thank you that helped us
great
uh yes so i have a question in
uh directly but directly modeling
observation space so i'm wondering so
how can we define them objective
using only the observations
yeah so
the model learning part is just kind of
a generative model i assume that you
mean the objective for the planning
process i guess the planning process
yeah so
there's a few different ways to do this
um
i think i probably don't have a backup
slide on it
uh yeah so there's a few different ways
you can do it one is to train a
classifier
um actually in the classifier is what
was done
in this earlier example i didn't
actually tell you that it was using
images but
um this example right here was actually
training using a binary classifier and
we evaluated that binary classifier on
the predicted images
and that's kind of one pretty effective
way for doing this
in these cases we're actually doing it a
little bit differently so we're telling
it to move a pixel to a certain position
and
then you need to actually evaluate for a
video prediction where the pixels moved
and the way that we did it in this case
is we actually used a video prediction
model that isn't trying to directly
output pixel values but it's actually
outputting how pixel value how pixels
will move
and it's doing that in a differentiable
way
uh and this allows us to kind of
implicitly
um implicitly use the model's
predictions about how pixels move in the
objective itself actually
um
so the way that it works is kind of
i don't really want to go into these
full details in the lecture um but the
way that it works is it predicts these
kernels that predict how images will
move these kernels are applied to the
image to predict a transformed image
and then these different transformed
images are composed to comp to produce
the the image itself and then this whole
architecture is trained end to end with
regard to the reconstruction error of
this frame
and then when we're planning for that
pixel for moving pixels we actually look
at the kernels itself and how it's
predicting how it predicts that that
pixels will move in the future and we
use that to evaluate the
uh the reward
so from my understanding that so this
kind of definition of goal still
is some kind of uses the latent space
for example when we train a classifier
and i can do the last layer before the
output has some kind of laser space
so
you can view it like that it isn't um it
isn't that the last layer isn't being
used in any way of the classifier so
we um
we're only out we're only using kind of
the output of the classifier when we're
planning
uh we're just using kind of whether it
predicts that this was a success or
whether it predicts that it was a
failure and then the planning is done in
the in the image space and the predicted
images are passed into the classifier
yes so for for example when when you uh
optimize the model in the observation
space when you use the
uh images directly so for example if you
are still using l2 or loss so i i kind
of think that this kind of loss may not
characterize the situation very well
yeah
so
for example
yeah so for the model training um
a lot of the models i showed were
actually deterministic and optimized
with regard to an l2 loss
but a lot of the kind of more recent
models that are very accurate don't use
l2 loss directly so this model for
example uses latent variables
like a like a vae style model to capture
its uncertainty and what will happen in
the future
um
these latent variables aren't equivalent
to a latent space they aren't they
aren't capturing kind of exactly what
the state is
but they are able to capture the
um
kind of the uncertainty about the future
um so you can use like a vae style loss
which has which is kind of l2
reconstruction or something like l2
reconstruction plus a kl term
there are also models that use gown
style losses to optimize the model
predictions
um
and there are also methods that use that
kind of optimized likelihood for example
yeah
thank you so much
great and then it's asking at the chat
explaining why hindsight experience
replay works well
so
let's go back to the beginning here um
and actually i like doing it using this
example so
one of the reasons
why it works well or kind of the
intuition is that
if you
if you have a lot of different tasks
that you want to accomplish a lot of
different goals that you want to figure
out how to reach
a standard approach would just keep the
data completely separate for those
different goals
and basically practice
this task of passing a lot practice this
task of shooting a lot and so forth and
keep the data completely separate
however when you attempt one task you
often end up kind of reaching a
different task or reaching a different
goal on accident
and you can use those accidental
successes
to actually help train the other tasks
and by using those you can actually kind
of share data across tasks and when
you're trying to reach
a large number of different goals this
process allows you to be significantly
more efficient
basically by sharing data across all of
your tasks then if you were to try to
attempt the task
individually
another reason for why it works is that
if one task has a is easier than another
task they can actually help provide a
little bit of a curriculum
because practicing that task will give
you some reward signal for the correct
solution
and that will allow you to
um
getting some kind of signal for that
will help actually allow you to explore
in different ways because you'll know
how to solve that and then when you
solve that task you'll accidentally
solve other tasks and and so forth
um so kind of the intuition is that it
allows you to share data across
different goals and it allows it gives
you kind of signal for um
it gives you kind of reward signal for
things that you accomplished on accident
when um when trying to solve a different
task
oh let's see there's one more question
so while choosing tasks would this also
mean that the entropy of the task goals
for the tasks we choose
should be high to maximize this
um
[Music]
right so if you
when you're kind of going about
collecting data
you need to choose some distribution of
our goals that you want to pass your
policy to try to accomplish
uh
there are some approaches that basically
try to kind of reach
a much wider range of goals
in order to help explore rather than
just reaching a very narrow set of goals
and this sort of kind of maximum entropy
over goals can be an effective technique
for trying to explore
so um one example paper that you could
look at that does something like that is
called skufit
and it's by a vichy pong
at
all
okay
great i'll see everyone